u.s. News reports elite colleges don't
buy happiness for graduates a new a
major new survey by Gallup finds that it
isn't where you go to college that is
predictive of whether you are successful
at work and happy in life whether it
matters what you do while you're in
school
the counts the poll didn't measure
graduates earnings rather it was rooted
in 30 years of Gallup research that
shows the people who feel happy and
engaged in their jobs are the most
productive that relatively small group
at the top didn't disproportionately
attend the prestigious schools that
Americans have long believed provided
golden ticket to success instead they
forged meaningful connections with
professors or mentors made significant
investments in long-term academic
projects and extracurricular activities
it matters very little where you go it's
how you do it that counts says Brandon
busted the executive director of Gallup
education having a teacher who believes
in a student makes a lifetime of
difference well there's tons of data out
there on elite colleges and there
whether they are predictive of a
successful life now you do have to
define successful life if you define
success only as money which I do not
that then you'd have you know you could
look at that I guess but you know I look
at look at it as the ability to
accomplish your goals
what are your goals and what are your a
bit what is your ability to accomplish
your goals does a a an elite college an
elite University is it predictive of
your ability to do that see it's not
your goals are most people's goals
anyway now if your goal is to work for a
certain firm a large corporate situation
that hires based on your not only your
degree but your pedigree then yeah but
that's literally
one two three percent of the jobs where
you went to school I went to Wharton
good that's a good thing it's a
wonderful school I went to Harvard great
that's awesome glad for you but but the
number of jobs that care and the number
of careers that care is very very very
small Wall Street Journal did a huge
project on this where they found that
the vast majority of CEOs and CFOs even
of Fortune 500 companies the top
companies out there the vast majority of
them graduate from state schools now
it's not predictive of you being the CEO
of a fortune 500 company that you get a
business degree from X or Y it has to do
with your choices after that and how you
choose to do this now I'm not advocating
a someone being ignorant I'm not
advocating someone not studying and not
getting an education but I'll tell you
this here's a weird one too Tom Stanley
who wrote the book million or next door
did in a second book called the
millionaire mind where he studied people
with ten million dollar net worths deca
millionaires and people that have seven
or $50,000 income and above now that's
called rich by the way they're not
millionaires they're deca millionaires
and they make seven or 50,000 a year or
more and he studied these people and he
study found 38 correlating demographic
and miscellaneous statistical pieces of
information character qualities
everything he found 38 correlating
standing rank them in order of of their
probability as to whether or not they
were predictive in other words whether
they were causal in this study and Tom's
a research analyst so he does he does
research professionally it's not
antidotal it's real you know the number
one predictor of a deca millionaire was
in his study integrity fnatic
levels of integrity well that's the
opposite of what crazy left-wingers way
out there tell you hadn't it crazy
right-wingers - I know right-wingers
that are way off the edge on the right
wing and they say stuff like well a
little man can't get ahead funny thing
is it's the same thing the left wingers
say usually got some victim mentality to
it
integrity number one indicator in the
top five was a successful marriage over
an extended period of time
supportive spouse in the top five as a
predictor a causal research element that
shows the likelihood of deca millionaire
isn't that interesting so here's what's
interesting
you're the quality of your spouse is
more predictive of your future success
than where you went to school Oh
boom yeah it's funny the Bible said that
who can find a virtuous wife it says in
proverbs 31 for her worth is far above
rubies the heart of her husband safely
trusts her and he will have no lack of
gain that's what the scripture says
isn't that interesting and you know
what's way down on the list and I was
really thinking the Lord for this one
way down the list down towards the
bottom in the bottom third of the
predictive so in other words it was the
least one of the lesser occurring things
that he studied your GPA that's good for
me because I was the portion of the
class that allowed the top half to be
there so I'm glad that that's not
predictive by the way you can break
through these things you know you don't
have a supportive spouse you you know
you do have a big GPA you do did go to
an elite school you can succeed anyway
by making good choices and having
integrity but I mean it's just
interesting to study what we think
causes success and then what really
causes it because we tell
you know eat your vegetables get good
grades so you can grow up and get a good
job right so we tell people and listen
I'm not I'm not here saying that kids
don't need to get good grades I was hard
on my kids I made him study and I'm
proud of my son who just graduated magna
[ __ ] laude in top 7% of his class and
from college I'm real proud of him for
that but I know that he's going to be
successful and it'll have very little to
do with the GPA of what he had versus
the guy who walked her across the stage
behind him or in front of the gal that
walked across in front of him it's got
to do this character and his work ethic
and his worthy hustles and whether he
grinds and whether he pushes and whether
he won't accept no and whether he moves
the immovable and whether he's a warrior
in the marketplace and imposes his will
on the marketplace and has a
conversation with the marketplace and
finds a way to serve with scale in the
marketplace these are the things that
are predictive of you being successful
not where you went to school darling is
it bad to go to an expensive in high
school no it's not bad but it is bad to
lie to people about it and tell them
that that causes success because there's
almost none of your CEOs and CFOs or
fortune 500 companies none of the
studies no the research indicates that
the ROI is there well I made connections
that really helped me in my life great
by the way so to die at a state school
with all those people who were hustlers
and grinders go out of hustle not a
grind blue-collar kids grew up like I
did you got to kill it and drag it home
baby so I mean it you know is it good to
hang around with smart well-heeled
people yes it is and but just be careful
where you think success comes from
because what it leads to is hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of thousands of
dollars of student loan debt
chasing mythology
so if you had to pay sticker price for
Harvard and go in debt to do it what
we're saying is there's absolutely not a
single piece of research that says it's
worth it now a lot of people get to go
to Harvard they don't pay sticker price
a lot of people get to go to Harvard and
pay cash for it mommy and daddy do and
I'm fine with that
I'm picking on Harvard or Vanderbilt or
Yale or whoever else that's super
expensive out there
Wharton but they're great schools but be
careful where you think success comes
from I know a lot of very wealthy very
successful people in virtually every
field hundreds and hundreds of them that
I've got been blessed to meet in the
last few years and not a one of them
will tell you it's because of where they
went to school
you